in our last high-speed video you saw
caesium and it was really good the way
it reacted quite violently but then we
thought we should have put an indicator
in the water to see what happened water
did it go alkali as one might expect and
how fast as the indicator change so now
we're going to show you rubidium and in
this experiment we put phenolphthalein
and indicate into the water which has
the advantage it's colorless in mildly
acidic water and pink
if the
well it's quite complicated what
happened so I want you to watch with me
on my computer and I'll try and explain
to you what I can see and then you can
look at the videos and see what else you
can see as well
so what we've got here and it's almost
life-size because this is the actual
trough here but with no water in it
we've got trough of water and then
ampoule with five grams I think it was
five grams of rubidium here it had
almost melted by the time the experiment
started and the hammer is just coming
down here the hammer you remember is our
so small metallic Collider for breaking
glass ampoules and here it's coming and
it hits the ampoule and breaks it
[Music]
it is broken the ampoule about here
above the metal so there's a large lump
of ampoule falling down with some
rubidium inside it here I put some metal
things in to pretend it's rubidium
and you can see it is hitting the water
just about there and there's some tiny
pieces of rubidium coming down here with
white smoke trails because that's
reacting with the water vapor in the air
[Music]
but what I think is exciting is that
this whole trough starts flexing around
and it's really hard to bend and even
Brady who's tougher than me can't bend
it very much so and it's jumping about
really very strongly and now the
reaction continues there is a small
piece of rubidium metal that has jumped
out when the rubidium lands it hit some
water and itself explodes on the ground
now I should have explained that in
front of this there was a plastic shield
so you will see bits of water hitting
the shield rather like the water hitting
the windshield of a car
[Music]
now the interesting thing is if you
watch carefully there's another
explosion so not just one but the whole
thing starts all over again
and there's another eruption with the
flexing of the plastic bowl so what I
think has happened is that when this
tube goes into the water water rushes in
and reacts with the rubidium producing
explosively in amount of hydrogen and
that this great rush of gas blows all
the water out of the tube so the
reaction stops and then the water goes
back in again and you get another
reaction and perhaps that happens two or
three times by luck because we didn't
smash the tube at the bottom so all the
metal got wet at the same time we've got
a repeat performance without having to
have an action replay or whatever so you
get several reactions for the price of
one so I'm just winding it back again
because there's something else which you
might have noticed but I only want
noticed on the second or third time so
what you'll see in various points is
that there is a strong purple color or
perhaps lilac might be better which is
actually the emission of light from the
vapor of the rubidium in fact rubidium
is well known to give this rather nice
color and everything is getting so hot
that you can see emissions here here and
so on of this light which is perhaps
slightly masked by the pink color of the
indicator indicators like this one are
acids which react with an alkali and
change their structure and change their
color in this particular case with
phenolphthalein the acid is colorless
and when you change structure it gets
red nil get cleaner MO and the reason it
goes red is that as the structure
changes the energy levels of the
electrons within the molecule both
change and so they absorb visible light
and it looks red because in fact it's
absorbing blue light so the red light
can still get through and this reaction
is very fast because what happens is
that H+ and OH h- ions are moving around
very rapidly and they move through water
at a very high speed and so the reaction
takes place very much faster than the
speed of our camera the rubidium
hydroxide or is reacting with the acid
the indy colorless indicator to make
rubidium phenol thoroughly plus water
so in effect h+ is leaving the acid and
reacting with our h- to give water
[Music]